brigitte 70 ans est une habituée et son
café c'est juste avant d'aller
travailler surtout ne lui parlez pas de
retraite je parle traitements tels que
retraite mois furent qui 35 heures et je
suis inquiet 35 heures en kit ou sombres
ou 35 heures je le faisais quand j'avais
14 ans dans deux jours à tuer ta vie qui
ne pas contracter un monde
ma fille m'a retiré
mon père elle est au travail le matin
très tôt on prenait le petit déjeuner
sans se parler en écoutant la radio
puis partez c'est mon vieux c'est et
puis après le soir est rentré tard
il mangeait avec nous il faisait la
vaisselle et puis on allait se coucher
quoi pour moi mon père c'est celui qui
est devant qui conduit la voiture
c'est donc c'est une nuque mais en
revanche moi ils m'ont perdu souvent mes
parents à bonbons way et ma grand-mère
au sikkim élevé et mes parents et ma
mère c'était un peu la la mode on va
dire elle m'a mis en laisse non à moi je
voyage toujours ou pas n'ont qu'un pas
non mais moi si oui ma mère me mettant
l'aise parce qu'en fait allusion mais
elle me paumer dans les magasins et se
faisait elle s'est engueulée par les
gens qui l'insultait en mai vous êtes
une mère indigne et mais si je n'attache
pas je te perds
vous voulez jouer aux cartes aux échecs
avec votre grand père isolé pour cause
de coheed et bien c'est désormais
possible tout comme pierre d'ailleurs
une séance de shopping avec votre
meilleure copine pour acheter la robe
que vous voulez porter dans la vie
réelle ou pour votre avatar dans le
monde virtuel et on peut aller en
vacances à batignolles
bah y'a du soleil je crois là bas
beaucoup
étaient dans le sud n'ont emmanuel on
vous suggérerais bien de prendre des
cours avec notre prof mélanie mais pas
sûr que ce soit productif oui parce que
mélanie c'est la seul prof de géo qui
comme et passagers au stade vers
montpellier tout guinéen d'angoulême on
voulait me un an avant mais ça va c'est
pas parce que je crois que j'ai ce
projet au qg connaître toutes les villes
patelin de france quoi
se déhancher en silence au milieu des
passants c'est possible on va les
suivantes autrement
spectacle étrange avec leurs casques les
élèves de secours appelés aion live
traduction shooté à la vie écoute la
même musique
attention ça glisse
mais très vite les deux amis se rendent
compte que la navigation dans les gorges
est loin d'être facile en plein milieu
de l'été il ya de l'affluence alors
ça se frôlent
tu vois ça ça veut dire famille et
d'hygiène
certains veulent que les hommes et les
femmes ne se mélangent pas dans la rue
et ils s'accrochent ça parce qu'ils
veulent que les fans marche sur ce
trottoir et les hommes sur l'autre
trottoir
[Musique]
on
des garçons
[Musique]
on ira adam
du confuse et intégra c'est pas
ben dis donc en comble où je suis plus
proche de raymond barre que j'en ai
marre de vous lire
on passe par ailleurs penser qu'ils sont
jaloux qu'ils connaissent pas raymond
barre et fait un premier ministre de la
france s'était un peu replié et jean
marc grâce à un plongeur
qu'est ce que dépense et au discours
hier à déjeuner penser à ça les choses
mais encore une fois pardon mais je j'en
parlerai volontiers avec vous dans
d'autres circonstances et ça n'est
absolument pas lieu de le faire et
comment vous dire ça avec peu
d'expérience
que l'acteur j'ai bien failli l'acteur
pourquoi vous pensez que c'est un sketch
pourquoi
leicester a doctor
[Musique]
je pensais que naquit fout les boules
bienvenus
vous pensez qu'il fallait dire quelque
chose comme ça non du tout pas
j'étais porte parole du gouvernement
pendant cinq ans quand un porte parole
n'a pas envie de répondre à une question
vous pouvez lui faire à l'endroit
il ya toutes les techniques pour ne pas
y répondre et une fois qu'il a compris
le principe c'est advitam eternam petit
jeu vous reste pourquoi aujourd'hui je
vous répondrai pas le genre de produits